quel bosco in prigione benvenuti con i
tagli nuovissima è che il rum dovremmo
scappare dal pittore cattivo vuole
trasformarci in suoi dipinti come le
carte ma io sono già all'opera d'arte
con questa fase in testa che vuole
accollarsi alle tele e trasformati
dipinti evitare con i sui fiori è già
pronto
lasciate un bel mi piace portarsi
fortune per vedere un'altra escape from
ha cliccato mi piace passato entro
quattro secondi 432 scaduto se non mi
seguite ancora inseguire e mettetevi
comodi presi con carne abbiamo due video
parlando 3 ski promo e così qua allora
ecco il pittore pazzo e ha detto che noi
potremmo diventare dei bellissimi
dipinti o no l'artista è impazzito ecc
ha chiuso dentro lo trovo un bottone per
aprire la porta semi a1 qui dove sarà
questo sì bravo
ma vitale già morta ormai la st meta e
capitale volto 25 volte 25.000 volte ha
nuovamente vediamo questa volta chi
conta quante volte muore vitale e poi si
rimettono dei commenti
l'altra volta aver chiesto contatti
fotografare vita e mi avete risposto
dobbiamo saltare nella vernice visto una
cosa che non correrò bisogna no vabbè è
difficilissimo questo piano piano a
dobbiamo difficile camminare sul
pannello certo giocato a volte vitale se
non fa di certo però mi piace il mio
outfit se avete se avete eletto lo
scorso video in cui togliamo
nell'ascensore pauroso fantasticati che
avete già visto il mio nuovo vestito
bianco prima ideali da fata vitale
continua a morire
no no guarda non ci credo non so se sarà
di questi io vado con quello centrale ma
non era quello centrale
proviamo in celeste no no
il verde arrivo verde pieno di vernice
perché era attento io sono già più brava
e adesso che dobbiamo fare qua dobbiamo
salire ad uscire fuori
forse dobbiamo salire qui su queste
mensole mettiamo col magazzino quando
tale tinte quanto accaduto devo
ricominciare tutto daccapo adesso che
fosse questa è finita c'è scritto o no
l'artista è enorme
ho paura che se vogliamo arrivare anche
lui vi ricordate che ci ha voluto
mangiare il dottore presidente del
dottore 27 vaiolo anch'io e non le avete
viste andate a vederli dopo questo video
comunque mi sa che dobbiamo finire nella
sub cancro ma tutto è rimasto ragionato
su un pannello signa ha spirato nella
sua bocca da evitare qui farcela anche
se siamo caduti
non sono stato chiamato ma non ha fatto
niente io no
la miss fratello per terra non finiscono
direttamente fatto cadere qua
eccomi sono saltato direttamente dentro
non lo so
allora qui abbiamo le nostre griglie ha
chiarito sbaglio però dove posso farlo
anche le ali sono questi globuli rossi
ma ha mangiato delle ossa interno contro
pesaro
ma se il cuore l'iran o troppo tardi
ceduto raggiunta dai puoi farcela
contiamo su di te arrivando sta
arrivando
sono questi a queste sono tipo pastelli
maestà una volta primo stelle io
aggiunge i pastelli interi questo
pittore che mi sa che siamo finiti in
quella parte lì
no io lo odio questo basta da è secolo
notare i festini mit arrivato july gira
poco badin saltare due volte sempre
[Musica]
[Applauso]
che è successo mi dispiace mi aggiorna
le trasportato qua arrivo capitale ce
l'ho fatta e ora è aspetta aspetta tempo
sanno fare qui qua sparano delle tinte
che sicuramente si fanno fuori ma
ovviamente questa tinta vera 6
resistente alla tinta verde
piano piano attenta league olearia sì mi
sa che le ali non sono l'idea che
sembrava andare come dentro vediamo sì o
no aspettato abbastanza strana qui
bisogna solo avviciniamo nel
dipartimento di uncinetto cucire gli
dobbiamo saltare ma ci crede che se l'ho
fatta il primo tentativo ci credo
aumentare più avanti diverse località
un signore ma non so se avete notato ma
vitale finalmente ad essere con carlo
scarpa se lo avete scritto voi ma farc
evitare senza scarpa che assumono e come
pittore cattivo dice vuoi guardare la
mia opera d'arte
la mia nuova opera d'arte e dice
sbrigati salta dentro al dipinto ok già
rinchiuso in prigione c'è scritto il
dipinto deve essere stata una sorta di
sotterraneo cerca di scavare trobiani a
per scappare non scappare dal generale
quadro si era una trappola dai possiamo
forza no eccovi tale da farvi 7
divertente quando è appena salta
superato uno di questi ostacoli e vedi
l'altro che si sfracella via poi
riusciti a scappare ho sottoscritto
siamo fuori ma dobbiamo riuscire a
tornare a casa è ok bisogna saltare solo
morrissey bene questi fiori né consorte
art shop
non ci credo che devo dare i siti a
scappare in forse manca poco
penso di sì io voglio questi fiori li
posso prendere solo viva andare lì
ok dai possiamo fare ci sono quasi
ultimati scritto che ci siamo riusciti
noto prendiamo il bel viva siccome è
stato passi c'era poco questo direi di
provare un altro di questi giochi che ci
consiglia un programma troviamo questo
mostro gigante guarda che paura oppure
questa guerra
questa è appeso tipo ad una gruccia lo
vedi o quale preferisci turno col mostro
gigante ok abbiamo descritto che i pesci
sono scappati lì sono liberi e quindi
dobbiamo scappare ma dove siamo ora
quindi in un acquario in un acquario
wow che le altre cose sono sistemati
pensi quasi anche uno squalo ma dovete
portare a sopra i pesci ok questo coso
qua sopra la medusa non ho bisogno
progettato anche bello se anche il
castello di sabbia qua dentro
wow adoro questa amministrazione a si
possa stare anche sopra no non si può si
può saltare questi dubbi lo schizzo si
sale su per attenti ai tubi che perdono
ecco i fatti
no è che succeda matrici scoperti
nell'acqua per attenti qua vita è
riuscito a 6
oggi posso credere bisogna stare attenti
perché bisogna scendere il percorso
giusto
salta in mente anche così si prolungo
con la quale io mi godo lo spettacolo di
comunità si struggeva scritto stai
attento al polpo gigante è un porco quel
vostro o no dall'immagine non si capiva
che era un bluff non mi diedi dobbiamo
entrare anche nella sua bocca
allora provo io abbia cesare baj si può
allora siamo meno sotto mubarak ed enti
ma perché dovevo sempre finire nella
bocca che partano allora forse si sogna
la vendita di limitare questi sì forse
sono le 20 sono piatti ce l'ho fatta io
dove sei sono in quello dopo equa
abbiamo però stragelato l'asi kato
secco vitale perché ho imparato
tantissimo guarda siamo quasi
sì ce l'abbiamo fatta ma bisogna saltare
questo polipo e super colorati altro
pezzo breve i do mai riuscito lo ammetto
che ho fatto e sono morta né al
sfracellato ma mi ha fatto uscire
sir
praticamente sono uscita pezzetti ma mi
ha comunque salvato e non so come ma ce
l'ho fatta
iniziamo ad andare vitale si arriva ecco
evitare c'era una sta attento a non
toccare l'inchiostro del calamaro che il
piano piano prati dove siamo vicini e
stiamo per farsela o dove dobbiamo
andare un labirinto qua come guarda qua
c'è un sacco
speriamo ci sono un sacco di strada in
questo caso anche dobbiamo andare qua
allora facciamo un lavoro di squadra
tu da che parte vaio è labirinto dove
sei non ti trovo dio sarà bloccato da
qualche parte facciamo non ci dovevamo
separare non è così sono quei ragazzi di
bra
abbiamo civica labirinto bisogna stare
su questi pesci che carini no è arrivato
8 abbiamo scritto sembra anche che in
quest'area si era stato ridipinto
sibelli di lo stanno ridipinge stampa la
vernice o no questo è difficilissimo
bisogna stare tripoli
nell'uno piano ma come non sono ancora
rassegnata fatta
ok anch'io sono un fatto andiamo noi
siamo in un magazzino ci saranno i pesci
presenti non devi andare le scale sono
accorto
eccoci vice alta giusta o no
era un pesce velenoso forse ce l'abbiamo
fatta fa ragazzi qua ci sono gli altri
negozi eco l'acquario ha descritto si
sono uniti e abbiamo superato lo stato
mi piace per vederne altre ora vi
lasciamo 4 castellini cliccare per
vedere inoltre altri video se preferite
una visione